freunde der sonne ihr habt viele fragen
habe diese ist besonders häufig es geht
um handys wlan und darum dass wir
ständig bestrahlt werden ist das jetzt
gefährlicher elektrosmog oder unnötige
panikmache um das zu klären habe ich
mich heute mails kurz gesagt
zusammengestutzt jetzt das ist die
collage auf die wir alle schon gewartet
haben und wenn ihr bei diesem thema
wirklich durchsteigen möchtet dann
solltet ihr euch auch unbedingt beide
videos anschauen
die reihenfolge ist sogar egal
hauptsache bekommt die ganze story falls
sie gerade von kurz gesagt kommt und
natürlich auch high von mir ist auch
immer ihr schon zu diesem thema wisst 1
fällt auf es scheint es wenige studien
mit menschen zu geben bei diesen wenigen
studien ist anscheinend keine dabei der
sich jemand hinstellt und sagt so
hiermit ist bewiesen dass handystrahlung
für menschen ungefährlich ist warum
eigentlich nichts im leben in einer zeit
des technischen fortschritts von
menschen auf den mond fliegen können
warum ist es nicht möglich diese fragen
wissenschaftlich zu beantworten oder
sonst etwas verheimlicht freunde der
sonne holt euch ein thema hat es euch
gemütlich wir gehen der sache auf den
grund
[Musik]
erst mal eine ganz kurze einleitung
kurz gesagt quasi handy und wlan
strahlung ist mikrowellenstrahlung wir
vom mikrowellenherd ist kann diese
strahlung gewebe erwärmen je intensiver
die strahlung desto stärker die
erwärmung auch ohne dass wir jetzt
gleich gebraten werden kann erwärmung
gesundheitsschädlich sein
deshalb gibt es für handys wählern usw
grenzwerte die verhindern da ist zum
beispiel der kopf beim telefonieren
jetzt nicht schädlich erwärmt wird
für kopf erhitzung gibt natürlich noch
andere gefahrenquellen dass ich solch
ein shampoo ohne ich mitbringen
die frage ist jetzt trotz der einhaltung
dieser grenzwerte kann handystrahlung
oder bildern strahlung doch
gesundheitsschädlich sein und zwar
aufgrund von irgendwelchen biologischen
prozessen die über diese erwärmung
hinausgehen also so genannte nicht
thermische effekte
hier gibt es einige sorgen befürchtungen
von leichten beschwerden wie
kopfschmerzen oder unwohlsein bis hin zu
der angst vor schwerwiegenden folgen wie
unfruchtbarkeit oder krebs ist da was
dran nehmen wir mal die sorge krebs als
konkretes beispiel
jetzt stellt euch vor ihr wert forscher
und die müsste die frage beantworten
kann handystrahlung beim menschen krebs
auslösen und ich meine es wirklich ernst
also stellt euch wirklich vor
wir machen jetzt eine art
gedankenexperiment denn es gibt zu
diesem thema tatsächlich gar nicht so
wenige wissenschaftliche ergebnisse aber
nur wenn ihr lernt wie eine forscherin
zu denken nur dann könnt ihr diese
ergebnisse auch sinnvoll einordnen und
interpretieren und diese allgemeine
denken könnt ihr in zukunft auch auf
alle möglichen anderen
wissenschaftlichen team anwenden die
forschung geht es nicht nur um die
forschungsfrage in diesem fall kann
handy strahlung krebs verursachen
sondern immer auch umgeht methoden das
bedeutet was wir denn genau anstellen um
diese frage zu beantworten also was
stellen wir solche medizinischen fragen
fängt man in der regel im labor das
bedeutet verschiedene experimente mit
zellen in vitro sagt man auch dazu und
versuche an lebenden organismen sprich
tierversuche auch in ivo genannt konkret
heißt das würde zellen und tiere
bestrahlen und schauen ob irgendetwas
passiert und dabei könnt ihr sehr
systematisch vorgehen ihr könnt
labortiere zum beispiel sehr gut
vergleichen weil sie so gezüchtet sind
dass sie genetisch gleich oder sehr
ähnlich
da könnt ihr sicher stellen dass
unterschiede eben nicht auf genetische
unterschiede zurückzuführen sind und ihr
könnt auch die dauer und die intensität
der bestrahlung sehr genau einstellen
und so stellt ihr vielleicht fest dass
ab einer gewissen strahlendosis eine
bestimmte krebsart häufiger auftritt
wenn das passiert ist das ein
ernstzunehmender hinweis sehen wir
weiter verfolgen ist und übrigens je
nachdem wie eindeutig die ergebnisse und
wie stark der effekt ist kann das
bereits ausreichend um die grenzwerte zu
senken
denn hier gilt das vorsorgeprinzip wir
müssen hier nicht und wollen auch nicht
darauf warten dass die schädlichkeit an
menschen eindeutig belegt ist es reicht
wenn eine gefahr
realistischerweise anzunehmen ist doch
die zelle und tierversuche reichen eben
nicht aus um die schädlichkeit an
menschen zu bestimmen
dafür müsst ihr ausgehend von ihren
laborversuchen studien an menschen durch
hören nur wie geht ihr da am besten vor
lasst mal rein systematisch denken und
noch nicht menschlich es ist ja nur ein
gedankenexperiment dann wäre ein gutes
studiendesign eine sogenannte
randomisierte kontrollierte studie
kontrolliert bedeutet ihr habt neben
einer testgruppe auch eine
kontrollgruppe die test konkurriert mit
handystrahlung bestrahlt die
kontrollgruppe nicht geschaut ob es
unterschiede haben dominiert heißt die
einteilung im test und kontrollgruppe
übernehmen nicht ihr sondern ein
computer zufalls programm
so habt ihr auch keine chance durch die
einteilung in die gruppen das ergebnis
zu verfälschen
ihr seht ja selbst was jetzt die
herausforderung ist im gegensatz zu
labormäusen die ihr super vergleichen
konnte habt ihr jetzt viele verschiedene
individuelle menschen die sich stark
unterscheiden nicht nur genetisch
sondern auch im lebensstil also wie sie
sich ernähren
ob die sport machen aber auch in deren
umwelt ja wo die leben ob die viele
abgase einatmen und es ist schon schwer
genug
handystrahlung alleine von diesen
anderen faktoren zu trennen
da ist es wichtig dass sie zumindest die
versuchsteilnehmer möglichst zufällig in
pest und kontrollgruppe aufteilt damit
diese beiden gruppen am ende im schnitt
ähnlich sind und damit gut vergleichbar
außerdem ist so eine studie am besten
doppelt blind
doppelblind bedeutet erstens die
teilnehmer wissen nicht in welcher
gruppe sie sind also ob sie gerade
bestrahlt werden oder nicht und zweitens
ihr die forscher ist es auch nicht
gekriegt anonyme daten entwendet die aus
und erst wenn die auswertung fertig ist
darf diese verbindung gelüftet werden
damit ihr nicht mit euren persönlichen
erwartungen
das ergebnis beeinflusst oder verfälscht
sei es bewusst oder unbewusst im jahr
schon für wissenschaftler gilt traue
niemandem und vor allem nicht dir selbst
das studiendesign lando visierte
kontrollierte studie gilt als der
goldstandard in der evidenzbasierten
medizin
das bedeutet randomisierte kontrollierte
studien sind besonders aussagekräftig
doch für unsere konkrete frage nämlich
kann handystrahlung beim menschen krebs
verursachen kommt dieses schöne
studiendesign leider nicht in frage aus
mehreren gründen darunter erst wir
dürften menschen nicht bewusst in gefahr
bringen
zum test neuer medikamente sind
randomisierte kontrollierte studien
vertretbar denn das medikament hat sich
ja in vorangegangenen laborversuchen als
potenzielle heilung erwiesen
handystrahlung ist es andersrum hier hat
sich eine intensive strahlung im labor
als potenziell gefährlich herausgestellt
und auch wenn nur verdacht auf eine
gefährdung besteht darf ich studieren
teilnehmer aus ethischen gründen nicht
systematisch schaden zufügen klarer wird
dass wenn wir jetzt ein krasses beispiel
nehmen zum beispiel jemand raucht eine
schachtel zigaretten pro tag
dann kann ich diese personen
wissenschaftlich beobachten aber ich
darf diese person nicht dazu auffordern
eine schachtel zigaretten pro tag zu
rauchen führende studie
das ist ethisch nicht vertretbar doch
selbst abgesehen davon zeigen dass
realisieren einer sinnvollen
kontrollgruppe ist quasi nicht möglich
ihr müsst es euch einfach nur vorstellen
eure kontrollgruppe darf ja keiner
strahlung ausgesetzt sein also keiner
handy schrank kann er weder schrank das
heißt ihr müsstet die kontrollgruppe
irgendwie in den wald setzen wo kein
empfang ist und selbst wenn wir das
hinbekommen würde dann wäre das ganze
erst nicht verblendet und zweitens
bekommt ihr noch ein ganz anderes
problem nämlich die leute sind ja dann
völlig von der außenwelt abgeschlossen
und damit wäre eure
troll gruppe wirklich nicht mehr
vergleichbar mit eurer testgruppe sagen
wir stellt fest dass die waldgruppe
gesünder lebt dann kann das an der
fehlenden handystrahlung liegen
es kann aber auch an alle möglichen
anderen liegen darin dass die leute sich
mehr bewegen mehr frische luft haben
vielleicht mehr schlafen und so weiter
oder man müsste beide gruppen in den
wald bringen und nur eine davon
bestrahlen aber dann werden wir auch
wieder beim ethischen probleme also ihr
seht selbst
das geht nicht also anders wenn wir die
frage nicht experimentell beantworten
können müssen wir beobachten beobachten
die studien sind ein wichtiger teil
evidenzbasierter medizin
ein beispiel ist die sogenannte
kohortenstudie eine kurze ist eine
gruppe von studienteilnehmern die ich
über einen langen zeitraum jahre oder
jahrzehnte hinweg beobachtet für unsere
frage kann handy strahlung krebs
verursachen brauchen wir eine gruppe von
menschen die zu studienbeginn alle
gesund sind die nächsten jahre checken
wie sie regelmäßig durch wir schauen wie
viele ihr handy benutzen und wie es mit
ihrer gesundheit steht und nach jahren
beobachten wir wie viele der teilnehmer
krebs bekommen haben und ob die
betroffenen sehr häufig ihr handy
benutzt haben oder eben auch nichts
klingt erstmal nach dem guten
studiendesign ist das prinzipiell auch
zum thema handystrahlung läuft jetzt im
moment eine große geworden studie wie
kostbar studie die untersucht ob
handystrahlung der gesundheit schaden
kann die studie hat ein auge auf hierzu
moore und auf andere mögliche
krankheiten und besteht aus sechs großen
kosten auf sechs verschiedenen
europäischen ländern die erste worte
startete 2007 und die studienteilnehmer
sollen insgesamt 20 bis 30 jahre lang
beobachtet werden während so eine
kohortenstudie nicht so systematisch ist
wie eine experimentelle studie nicht
genau da auch ein vorteil denn während
labor settings oft nicht alltags
relevant sind beobachten wir hier die
menschen in ihrem echten alltäglichen
leben und die echten realen auswirkungen
gibt es aber bei kohortenstudien einen
wesentlichen nachteil nämlich
kohortenstudien eignet sich nicht für
seltene krankheitsfällen sagen wir
hängen die strahlung löst in einem von
1000 fällen krebs
nur so als beispiel und wir beobachten
jetzt 10.000 menschen und zehn menschen
davon kriegen durch handystrahlung krebs
dann werden wir diesen effekt nicht
bemerken das könnt ihr euch schon selbst
denken seltene gefahren sind nur mit
riesigem garten studien zu beobachten
das ist schwierig und wir euch
vorstellen könnt auch ziemlich teuer was
kommt man denn noch machen wir können
statt einer sogenannten prospektiven
studie also vorausschauend eine
respektive studie machen also
zurückschauen was heißt es schauen wir
uns ein konkretes beispiel an nämlich
die case control studie besuchen uns
zwei gruppen von studienteilnehmern alle
mit krebs das ist die case gruppe und
eine gesunde gruppe die kontrollgruppe
case control studien eignen sich gesellt
in der krankheits findet denn ich suche
mir hier bewusst nur leute mit case aus
jetzt kommt das schwierige im gegensatz
zu einer kohortenstudie wo ich die
menschen jahrelang begleitete muss ich
jetzt versuchen rückblickend
herauszufinden wie viel strahlung diese
menschen ausgesetzt war in den letzten
jahren oder jahrzehnten und ob es einen
unterschied gab zwischen den case und
der kontrollgruppe
das meiste kriegt man nur durch
befragung heraus oder durch andere
ungenaue methoden zum beispiel schaut
man nicht handyverträge an und versucht
daraus zu schließen wie viel die
menschen ihr handy genutzt haben aber
akkurat gibt dass die strahlenbelastung
natürlich nicht wieder außerdem
unterliegen case control studien leicht
einem sogenannten recall bayers sagen
wir ich habe krebs und werde im rahmen
einer case control studie befragt wie
oft ich mein handy benutzt habe in den
letzten jahren
jetzt habe ich vielleicht schon mal
gehört dass handystrahlung krebs
irgendwie zusammenhängt und das führt
dazu dass ich mich viel stärker daran
erinnere wie oft ich mein handy benutzt
habe als jemand aus der kontrollgruppe
dieser recall bayers erinnerungs weiß
verzerrt also die ergebnisse der
befragung ist leuchtet euch
wahrscheinlich ein warum es auf die
frage kann handy strahlung krebs
verursachen bisher noch keine
eindeutigen antworten aus studien mit
menschen gibt das heißt jetzt aber auch
nicht dass wir wild behaupten können
dass handystrahlung gefährlich sei oder
dass sie insekten tötet oder was auch
immer man dazu hört das beruht auf
keinen wissenschaftlichen da das heißt
aber auch nicht dass wir jetzt völlig
hilflos
und für ihr unwissen bleiben wären wie
gesagt große gehörten studien laufen
derzeit noch aus dem habt ihr selbst
gesehen dass verschiedene methoden
verschiedene vor nachteile haben und
gute forschung zieht viele verschiedene
methoden hinzu und setzt die zusammen
wie eine art puzzle zum beispiel
brauchen wir neben diesen rechts
anwendungsbezogenen studien mit menschen
auch ein grundlegendes biochemisches
verständnis für die mechanismen die zum
beispiel hinter handy strahlung und
krebs stecken könnten und das ist sehr
wichtig es gibt bisher noch keine
schlüssige hypothese noch keine
vorstellung davon wie handy strahlung
krebs überhaupt theoretisch auslösen
könnte es gibt keinen plausiblen
biologischen mechanismus dafür das heißt
nicht dass man sich erforschen sollte
aber es ist ein gutes zeichen dafür dass
man nicht in panik verfallen sollte ich
würde jetzt an dieser stelle zur
visualisierung trägen aber es ist heute
einfach zu heiß in mein studio eine
jetzt genau wissen wollte welche
puzzleteile die forschung bisher
gesammelt hat was man mit gewissheit
sagen kann und was elektrosmog
eigentlich genau ist dann findet ihr
diese antworten bei kurz gesagt und wenn
ich schon mal da seid hinterlassen im
kurz gesagt teams auch gerne ein paar
kekse mochis vorher könnt ihr mir aber
gerne in den kommentaren verraten wie
ihr mit diesem thema im alltag umgeht
macht ihr euch sorgen unternehmen die
irgendwas also seht ihr euer handy
möglichst weit weg beim schlafen zum
beispiel oder seid ihr da ganz entspannt
und optimistisch schreibe es in die
kommentare wir sehen uns nächste woche
bis dahin bleibt sicher